quando lascerà mio figlio spererò con
tutto me stesso che sia un talento o in
alternativa che sia cocciuto che sia
brillante o in alternativa che abbia una
grande perseveranza
poi se poteste scegliere che cosa
preferireste un figlio con un intuito in
nato un figlio con una grande costanza
un figlio cocciuto con la testa dura
quali sono le due differenze poniamo che
esistono infinite ricette sbagliate per
fare la pizza è soltanto una decina di
ricette giuste per farla buona quella
filante quella come si deve
poniamo anche cappuccetto rosso debba
andare dalla nonna ed esistono cinque
strade in cui incontra il lupo e due in
cui non incontra ecco il talento ha la
capacità innata di imboccare la strada
giusta il sentiero senza beccare il lupo
arrivare dalla luna sano e salvo
beccare fin da subito il giusto mix di
ingredienti per fare la pizza buona
quella senza l'ananas senza un eccessivo
sforzo eseguire subito la sequenza di
mosse che porta il proprio piede a
tirare ea fare gol sotto il sette
palleggiare all'infinito senza far
cadere la palla intonare un dock a
orecchio ecco questa è l'attitudine del
talento certo che però dall'altra parte
un figlio che nasce senza talento è vero
che sbaglierà continuamente strada non
vincerà sulla breve distanza
probabilmente verrà divorato una decina
di volte dal lupo ma
se sopravviverà porterà con sé un
bagaglio di esperienza tale che
costituirà la sua conoscenza la sua
consapevolezza di sé e allora non è non
è mica facile scegliere da una parte il
talento dalla parte la consapevolezza
secondo voi quale delle due
virtù ha scelto l'essere umano
inconsapevolmente nel suo percorso
evolutivo l'essere umano e achille e la
tartaruga
l'essere umano e il bambino mozart o una
sequoia secolare e un lampo di genio e
la goccia che cade
imperterrita
e dopo mesi anni scava la roccia
secondo me è l'essere umano è intuito
allo stato puro l'essere umano e il
fenomeno ronaldo degli animali se
esistesse l'eni moles got talent
l'essere umano vincerebbe sfoggiando la
sua grande capacità la caratteristica
che lo rende unico la capacità di
prevedere il futuro di presagire un
evento di unire i puntini in una sola
parola l'intelletto
l'internet
l'intelletto
l'intelletto ci ha permesso di
soggiornare fin da subito tutti gli
altri esseri umani di domare il fuoco
poco per volta inventare la ruota
inventare la ronda ta il salto mortale
in avanti salto mortale all'indietro lo
yo yo il vestitino per cani le scoregge
sotto le ascelle di dominare la tecnica
e addomesticare le piante salire poco
per volta in cima alla catena alimentare
in cima alla piramide animale l'uomo è
diventato il faraone d'egitto e la queen
c'è una vista incredibile si vede ogni
cosa anche la signora in fondo tutto col
cellulare che fa un video si può portare
la via
l'uomo è qui ed è tutto certo che
l'equilibrio non è propriamente stabile
l'aria è rarefatta un po di attacchi di
panico non sono proprio fatto per stare
questo scendiamo quali sono stati gli
ingredienti e i processi grazie ai quali
l'intelletto ci ha portato quassù a
tutti noi no quassù
allora mi sono detto ok proviamo a
definirlo questo intelletto
immaginiamoci l'intelletto come una
grande sfera ce l'avete qui qui proprio
così con una grande sfera ecco mi sono
immaginato tre fasi fase 1 fase ii e
fase iii
fase 1
ad essere umano
nasce è senza dubbio a fase 1 e il
dubbio il punto interrogativo
mariolino a tre anni a malapena sa
camminare non sa andare in bicicletta sa
parlare si gira verso sua madre le
chiede perché cade una mela isacco la
guarda e si chiede perché
il sole scalda la parete margherita va
la tocca e si chiede perché calogero
viene colpito da un fulmine lo porto
peccato ma io ce lo guarda perché gli
altri animali non si chiedono perché
fanno e basta il gatto si pulisce
leccandosi se piace a lui ma non si
chiede perché è il cane scodinzola
quando è felice ma non si chiede cosa ci
sia dentro la sua coda il criceto va
tutto il giorno sulla ruota lo stavano
cosa si vota la curiosità la curiosità
ci ha permesso di prevedere il futuro ci
ha permesso di cercare di scoprire la
verità tanto ci delle risposte talvolta
delle risposte semplicissime altre volte
complesse ecco che arriviamo alla
seconda fase
il punto esclamativo l'essere umano si
da queste risposte
e poi ci crede ci crede ma noi che si
crede così alla leggera cioè le fa
diventare delle leggi delle fedi delle
credenze e queste credenze
non ha nulla a che vedere con l'istinto
degli animali che risponde alle leggi di
natura la devozione risponde alle leggi
umane di chi suppone di avere una
risposta
e laddove inizia a girare questo
circuito mi chiedo e ci credo mi chiedo
e ci credo mi chiedo ci credo arriva la
terza fase della più importante assoluto
siete curiosi è che siete esseri umani
ecco la terza fase
quando un essere umano non solo inizia a
credere alle proprie risposte ma tutti
gli altri intorno a lui iniziano a
crederci e ne mette uno in fila
all'altro in un ordine preciso in un
contesto specifico ha inventato il gioco
e chiunque partecipi al gioco decide di
seguire queste regole e quando quando
quando gioco esistono dei giocatori
esiste uno scopo esistono dei premi dei
vincitori e degli sconfitti e quando
gioco vivo in funzione di un obiettivo
entro una dimensione nella quale non mi
accorgo neanche che tutti i giorni ogni
secondo io sto a certe regole a certe
credenze
ma attenzione queste regole queste
credenze le siamo date noi sono le
risposte di prima
facciamo qualche esempio
la scienza la mela cade mi chiedo perché
la mela cade credo nel metodo analitico
gioco società mi chiedo perché condivide
il mio tempo credo nel bene comune gioco
mercato perché fatico tutti i giorni
credo nel progresso gioco così l'uomo
del medioevo
combatteva le sue crociate per dio
socrate moriva bevendo la cicuta per un
ideale il soldato americano cadeva in
normandia mille mila chilometri da casa
da solo al freddo per la patria per la
libertà per la democrazia così io non
butto per terra la carta la maestra non
dice le parolacce e ricercatori di
oxford pasta tutta la sua vita davanti
alla lavagna cercare di risolvere un
teorema così lei credere la famiglia lui
crede nella proprietà privata lui nelle
cripto valute ma niente di tutto questo
reale niente di tutto questo è vero sono
costrutti mentali che ci permettono di
pensare al di là dell'esistente e
giocare a rilancio il nonno di mio nonno
aveva una bellissima mela che aveva
raccolto e aveva paura di andare a
dormire perché pensava se qualcuno entra
qui di notte me la mancia cosa faccio
inventò la prigione come pena esemplare
per chiunque commetta un furto il mio
trisavolo aveva una bellissima casa una
villa anzi ma che dico una villa il mio
trisavolo era il re inventò l'eredità
sulla base di ipotesi e congetture
totalmente inventate abbiamo costruito
un impero che si regge in piedi da
secoli ma è una gigantesca bolla fatta
di convenzione inossidabile scritta nero
su bianco olio su tela luogo su capo
byte su silicio e ci viene da pensare
reggerà ma chi se ne importa se resterà
il sistema mi chiedo credo gioco
dell'intelletto ci ha permesso di vivere
affrancandoci dalla morte non pensare
chiusa di avere un senso vivere più
sicuri non pensare più alla fame non
avere più sete finalmente essere felici
in realtà non può essere felici
c'è qualcosa che non torna come ci siamo
arrivati fin quassù quali sono stati
i processi ci hanno portato fin che so
forse che non mi sento ancora a mio agio
come mai
ecco l'intelletto abbiamo detto che una
sfera facciamo un altro piccolo passo
indietro
questa sfera gigante a un certo punto
partorisce due gemelli è un tipo una
pancia della mamma partorisce due
gemelli si giochi i giochi di tipo 1 i
giochi di tipo 2 da una parte abbiamo
romolo da una parte abbiamo remo da una
parte abbiamo caino dall'altra parte
abele ecco i giochi di tipo 1
rispondono una semplice regola
la legge del più forte o schiacci o
viene schiacciato selezione naturale
questi giochi vengono messi in pratica
anche dagli altri animali da millenni li
usano per risolvere moltissimi problemi
legati per esempio al fabbisogno
energetico vedi lo squalo che mangia il
pesce più piccolo perché ha fame oppure
leone nella savana che diventa il re
assoluto ha almeno fino a quando non
arriva il cacciatore ecco questi tipi di
giochi giochi di tipo 1 richiamerei
verticali che premiano chi vince e
suscitano chi perde mettono più in alto
chi detiene più in basso chi rincorre
oppure scappa più un altro chi può più
in basso chi spera ciò che
contraddistingue per esempio il gioco
dittatura al gioco tirannia ma anche il
gioco scacchi il gioco olimpiadi il
gioco miss italia ai giochi monoteismo i
voti a scuola e poi il fratello gemello
i giochi di tipo 2 sono un po più
giovani giochi di tipo 2 mi piace
pensare
che gli abbiano inventati i due uomini
più scarsi in assoluto a giocare a
queste ci hanno saputo farsi scarsi come
erano stufi di perdere si sono guardati
sun deck erano prostitute più stupida
nei più scarse si sente ma se invece di
ammazzarsi a vicenda collabor assimo e
li inventano il gioco di tipo 2 ma non
lo inventano scoprono la legge che
regola la vita da millenni che va al di
là del più forte del più scarso del
sopra del sotto del primo del dopo i
giochi secondo cui
lavorando in squadra il talento del
singolo viene enormemente amplificato
secondo le leggi che gli scienziati
chiamano proprietà emergenti ma cosa
sono le proprietà emergenti
mi sono chiesto quando l'ho scoperto
sono letteralmente caduto dalla sedia po
piatto per terra ero diventato
orizzontale non riuscivo a capire le
leggi delle proprietà emergenti
ci dicono che le capacità sviluppate da
un organismo saranno sempre maggiori
delle cellule che locke che lo
compongono le capacità di una cellula
sono largamente superiori di tutte le
molecole che lo compongono e a loro
volta le molecole hanno delle capacità
che tutti gli atomi che le compongono
non hanno così come la resistenza di una
folta chioma largamente superiore di
quella di un singolo capello quella di
un ecosistema nella sua complessità e
totalmente maggiore rispetto a una
singola pianta
ecco i giochi di tipo 2 i giochi
orizzontali laddove nei giochi di tipo 1
il carburante era la competizione
il premio era la classifica l'obiettivo
era il benessere personale nei giochi di
tipo 2
l'egoismo del singolo viene sostituito
dalla potenza delle relazioni mors tua
vita mea viene sbugiardato da una
semplice operazione matematica tanto
semplice quanto folle 0 più 0 più
000 e
alla fine fa uno e qui si apre un bivio
da una parte la guerra per la
sopravvivenza dove vince il più forte
dall'altra la collaborazione la
cooperazione dove vince la comunità e
questi due tipi di giochi si scontrano
questi due mondi si mischiano e da
generazione a generazione gli uomini si
scambiano i libretti di istruzione dove
c'è scritto le regole del gioco qualcuno
le cambia alcuno le modifica si evolvono
ma allo stesso tempo rimangono entrambi
sia giochi di tipo 1 quelli verticali
sei giochi tipo 2 quelli orizzontali e
voi direte beh ma non c'è storia sono
molto meglio giochi orizzontali a
partire dal presupposto che non ci sia
bisogno della violenza eppure
il nostro stesso corpo e un sistema
gerarchico fondato sul capo che governa
e gli arti che eseguono amiamo gli
slogan impossible is nothing just do it
amiamo le grandi imprese di singoli
uomini
soli hanno varcato il limite riscrivendo
un pezzo di storia
cristoforo colombo in al masc steve jobs
louis armstrong
il musicista e anche l'astronauta
cristiano malgioglio amiamo le scritte
sui muri le strade con i nostri nomi le
mani nel cemento hollywood le statue di
marmo il museo delle cere finché su un
palco ci sarà una sola persona che parla
e 100 che ascoltano ci sarà qualcosa che
non torna e proprio questo sentimento
devozionale a renderci tutti schiavi in
un sistema ultra competitivo che non
solo premia chi vince ma lo idealizza
i perdenti non collaborano faranno di
tutto perché sono inorgogliti pur di far
valere la propria forza rispetto a
quelli in graduatoria inferiore e lo
scopo diventa vincere su e non vincere
con
bisognerebbe fare cento mille passi
indietro per affrancarci dalla sedia e
per affrancarci da tutte quelle credenze
che ci hanno fatto credere a punto che
l'esclusività sia uno status symbol
che il successo sia il mezzo per
arrivare a all'autodeterminazione
che l'ha ferito krazia
sia il luogo giusto per ritrovare e
nutrire la fiducia di sé lo schiavo deve
liberarsi del unito il popolo può fare a
meno delle icone non deve passare tutta
la vita ambendo diventarle
come stato sconfitto l'apartheid
con un movimento di modelli di vita che
non hanno deciso di diventare bianchi ma
hanno fatto di tutto per inventare dei
nuovi giochi
con nuovi ideali nuove fedi che
gradualmente hanno abbassato il vertice
della piramide rendendola una rete ecco
il percorso perfetto il percorso ideale
il mondo vegetale eco internet la più
grande invenzione che sia stata mai
creata dall essere umano
non gerarchica senza senza un inventore
non si sa chi ha inventato internet poi
ubuntu il sistema operativo libero open
source l'enciclopedia collettiva
wikipedia di wikipedia non so come si
dica che insieme a tanti altri giochi
sommati di tipo orizzontale hanno
contribuito ad abbassare questi piramide
rendendole sempre più basse di piramidi
globali e allora gli influencer devono
continuare in questa tendenza e devono
cercare di avere sempre meno followers i
re ad avere sempre meno sud i grandi
eroi devono sembrare di volta in volta
persone più normali superman greta
tandberg
e a quel punto
a quel punto
a quel punto probabilmente quando
nascerà mio figlio io spero con tutto me
stesso che non diventi un fenomeno un
talento un genio
spero che riconosca nella perseveranza
nella costanza un po di conoscenza e di
consapevolezza che lo porti a
riconoscersi non come un singolo
individuo sulla punta della tutela
piramide o sulla vetta della montagna
ma come parte integrante e
imprescindibile di un tutto molto più
grande di noi
[Musica]